sur un mec normal j'ai des connaissances
sur l'impact écologique et au quotidien
j'en fais pas assez
au final je crois qu'on ait beaucoup
comme ça j'ai une conscience écologique
inactive
je suis parti avec ecosia pour voir si
je pouvais réussir à l'activé pleinement
et évidemment j'ai pas été payés pour le
faire est évidemment j'ai filmé les
impacts directs parce que dans mon
quotidien il ya quelque chose que je
peux faire c'est parler à des milliers
de personnes nous sommes partis à 13
pour les mêmes raisons ou des raisons
plus personnelles pour mieux comprendre
ça sur place pour se rendre compte que
la reforestation ce n'est pas que le
bilan carbone et le réchauffement
climatique
nous sommes partis en tanzanie plutôt
que sur un site français qu évidemment
pour ça il a fallu prendre l'avion et
même si les billets ont été pris le plus
tard possible pour combler les sièges
vides
j'espère que cette vidéo compensera sans
fois le bilan carbone de mon voyage
alors voilà ce qui se passe le running
de tout ce voyage ça va être ce casse
tête là ça je vais le présenter à toutes
les personnes qui m'entourent et durant
ces dix jours leur but c'est de craquer
ce casse-tête à la toute fin de cette
vidéo vous aussi vous serez comment il
fonctionne c'est extrêmement ingénieux
il faut que vous le sachiez
et puis moi entre temps au milieu tout
ce voyage parmi tout ce que je vais vous
faire voir je vais essayer de résoudre
des casse têtes en bois parce que le
bois quand même peut être utile il ya
aussi le bois utile c'est important mais
ça on y reviendra aussi dans cette vidéo
là maintenant on repart direction le
cratère alors faire ce défi des casse
tête c'était aussi un moyen de rythme et
un petit peu notre voyage est aussi de
comprendre quelque chose
lors de sa résolution il faut savoir que
même en afrique j'essaye d'être un tant
soit peu présentables d'image mais en
fait je fais ça m'a parce que j'ai du
mascara partout dans les yeux ou quoi
c'est encore pire
ce voyage en plein hiver africains sans
eau chaude sans électricité sans wifi
avec quelque chose de magique aussi sur
le groupe et on s'est vraiment rencontré
aussi individuellement
tu me donnes ton casse tête là moi je
veux tester ton casse tête
je leur ai présenté le casse-tête de la
manière suivante il y a un grand cube de
bois avec un élastique coller à
l'extérieur un trou et une tige de bois
et leur but c'est de reproduire le même
geste que moi à savoir la tige qui
rentrent vivement à l'intérieur
[Musique]
où
avant de vous parler du cratère de
ngorongoro faut que je vous dise que
c'était dingue devant nous de voir des
animaux sauvages dans leur environnement
naturel de pouvoir les approcher même si
évidemment on ne descendait jamais de la
voiture on n'était pas bien équipés pour
voir les photos je vous recommande
d'aller voir la vidéo qui va sortir max
bird lui il a un appareil photo mon gars
qui est énorme
on a vu des hippopotames épouse comme
dirait margot
vraiment pause
pour notre premier jour en tanzanie
c'était des étoiles plein les yeux pour
nous on a même vu des petits pumba est
immonde c'est juste un bébé lion c'est
la seule phrase que je sais limitée et à
la sortie du parc
on a rencontré une grande famille de
singe dans la voiture lorsqu'on était
dans le cratère margot et williams alias
doc seven nous ont donné pas mal
d'informations qu'ils avaient emmagasiné
sur le cratère 326 kilomètres carrés
c'est à peu près trois fois la taille de
paris un diamètre de 20 km c'est un
ancien ball conquis s'est effondré sur
lui même si la montagne était resté
debout elle serait aujourd'hui plus
grande que le kilimandjaro
alors certes c'est une réserve naturelle
protégée on y trouve 400 espèces
d'oiseaux énormément d'animaux mais qui
sont ni plus ni moins figé intérieur
c'est un peu comme un grand jeu on veut
des jeeps à longueur de journée circuler
c'est ici qu'on retrouve le plus grand
nombre de lions et pourtant ils sont que
55 avec malheureusement des gros
problèmes de consanguinité et c'est ça
qui fait flipper quand tu te promènes en
tant qu ami tu croises pas d'autres
animaux à des endroits importants tu
devrais en croisé et ça c'est l'un des
premiers impacts de la déforestation et
de l'activité humaine visiter cette
réserve naturelle était merveilleux mais
savoir ce qu'on perd et voir ce qu'on
perd c'est vraiment différent
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième réveil en
tanzanie réveil de bonheur réveille dans
le froid très étonnant mais entendent à
lui il fait très froid la nuit parce
qu'on est en plein hiver en fait parce
qu'on est sous l'équateur
aujourd'hui on va aller au lac natron
qui est un lac au péage particulier
c'est un l'axé c'est quasiment de la
soude en fait cela qu'il faut qu'on va
aller voir ça le psy peut-être essayer
d'en profiter pour me poser pour essayer
de commencer à résoudre l'un des casse
tête que je voulais faire sur ce truc là
et puis continuer à proposer aux autres
de faire le fameux casse tête s'ils sont
toujours motivés a essayé de le
raisonner
je veux voir ce qu'il ya dedans on voit
rien ban envahie et pourquoi on a pas eu
vraiment c'est pas utile en place mais
si c'est utile bien sûr lorsque l'on est
en train de rouler le son est vraiment
pas terrible il y à aller en train de
comparer l'encoche qui assure la barre
par rapport à la position de l'élastique
d'asie mais en fait ça correspond pas et
l'élastique on s'en fout et ferdinand et
pas du tout de cet avis pour lui cette
élastique mais pas là pour rien c'est
vraiment amusant de voir de quelle
manière le mental de chacun va essayer
de résoudre
vous vous en pensez quoi est ce que vous
pensez qu'un élastique ou pas à
l'intérieur durant ce trajet pour aller
au lac natron c'est le seul moment on
n'a pas eu trop froid où la température
est acceptable c'est agréable pour nous
et là on a eu la plus magnifique des
surprises de tout le voyage ce genre de
chose ne s'est passé qu'une seule fois
mais cette fois là tu dis mais pourquoi
pourquoi c'est comme ça partout sont
vraiment quelques mètres on a arrêté la
voiture
on essaie de parler trop fort on les
approche pas les girafes ont autant d'os
dans le coup que nous ah oui et le shift
et quoi du concept de sept vertèbres je
crois c'est peut-être même le plus grand
d'afrique et le maïs baird
il aime les voir des dicos moi je vais
voir des girafes
quand je les ai vus j'ai eu aurait sauté
dessus montrent qu'ils voulaient voir
temps depuis hier je disais et en plus
ça c'était trop mignonne à ce soir et
cette scène nous au regard des gens
incroyables voir par ailleurs
j'ai vu mais il faut y a donc ça va trop
contente de voir dit après des heures de
trajet de marche on a enfin arrivé au
lac natron je vous recommande vivement
d'aller voir la vidéo que doc seven va
sortir dessus la fédé plan aux drones il
donne pas mal d'explications mois après
avoir visité j'en ai profité pour
commencer à essayer de résoudre l'un des
casse tête que j'ai emmené pour moi et
bien clairement cette première heure de
tests étaient un échec
je vous montre quelques images que j'ai
pu prendre avec mon trône du lac natron
le lac c'est ce qu'on voit tout au bout
à partir de ce jour là on va toujours
monter plus haut dans les montagnes va
faire toujours plus froid dans des
situations toujours plus inconfortable
et c'est comme ça qu'on va découvrir des
gens qui sont plus que concernés par la
déforestation les solutions qu'ils ont
trouvée et l'ensemble des bénéfices que
ça peut apporter
[Musique]
après 45 minutes d'attentes mari a
décidé de craquer eu quatre sets
ouais c'est du bluff fort tu fais ça et
en fait je suis fait je suis pas
célibataire regarder justement heureux
ce que je me suis posé la question cette
jupe ou la fille de prononcer le mot
magique que du bluff étude jette rien
fait une petite manière de le faire
regarde du cir alors tu d'affiner le
pack de le dire à personne dans lesquels
je m'en doutais depuis je sais pas
depuis j'ai vu un truc comme ça
bien qu'il ya un truc qui fait selon
qu'alors par contre je t'ai vu faire
est-ce que tu étais en train de faire
donc j'estime qu'il avait effectivement
voilà effectivement on a jamais vu
l'élastique se faire sortir ami
puisqu'il n'a pas c'est extraordinaire
c'est à dire que c'est pas seulement un
casse tête c'est un sortir de la boîte
c'est ça c'est un schéma mental et je
n'ai jamais dit qu'elle est un élastique
dedans jamais la javel oui c'est vrai
merci merci formidable a gardé secret je
garde le secret évidemment je prouverai
et on continue on faire reste toujours à
côté d'une centrale qui valence du
sulfure d'hydrogène dans nos poumons
depuis maintenant pas loin d'une heure
parce que nous avons est en panne alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que plus ou
moins rapidement tout le monde a réussi
à résoudre le casse-tête mais personne
ne s'est dit à fabien tu nous as eue
est-ce que ce n'était pas le but au
contraire les douze personnes qui ont
essayé et réussi durant ce voyage se
sont dit mais comment ça se fait alors
que j'avais tout sous les yeux qui avait
pas de consignes trompeuse que je suis
resté dans un schéma mental qui me
bloquait et dans lequel je me suis moi
même me est ce qui était génial pour moi
c'était de voir leur conscience changer
un moment pour le résoudre
et c'est aussi un petit peu en résonance
avec ce qu'on faisait là est ce qu'on
est en train de faire là et le pourquoi
peut-être vous regardez cette vidéo à
savoir on sait des choses on croit
savoir des choses mais mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour que ça change
et pourquoi on se conforte dans le
sentiment que ba on ne peut pas changer
tout ça je sais aussi qu'il ya des
personnes qui verront nos vidéos et qui
se diront oui encore 13 personnes issues
de youtube qui vont faire les beaux
quelque part en afrique
ce projet c'est un projet collectif de
quelque chose qui nous touche nous
personnellement on se sentaient
peut-être pas aussi les épaules de vivre
ça individuellement et surtout vous
connaissez déjà tous
ecosia et on en avait déjà tous parlé
sur nos chaînes c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
qu'on est dans cette démarche et echoes
ya c'est un moteur de recherche
alternatif qui sert à planter des arbres
est ce que vous allez voir dans la suite
de cette vidéo ça va vous rendre sa très
concret
[Musique]
alors là je vous présente 45 rochère sur
le site des causes ya 45 rochère 45
recherche et vous imaginez après ce que
ça donne
[Musique]
non
le break est faisable
ça prend du sens à ce que tu as est ce
que tu trouves que ça prend du temps où
l'âme nous qui connaissions exposé hier
mais surtout que nous là sur place on
voit aussi que c'est pas que des arbres
c'est aussi les 150 personnes qui
travaillent sur les piques sur la
pépinière les 1000 personnes qui
travaillent sur les plantations les 20%
des bénéfices que ça engendre au niveau
de tourisme qui seront passés
directement au niveau des villages pour
les écoles pour avoir de l'eau potable
c'est d'être une fois c'est pas que des
armes
[Musique]
alors ici on est dans la plus grande
pépinière de tanzanie c'est la deuxième
je vous ai fait voir peut-être avant
peut-être après des images de la
deuxième plus grande que c'est la plus
grande ya 20 millions de pousses
d'arbres qui sont plantés ici
mais j'oublie peuvent quand même que
j'ai ce casse-tête aussi en bois à
résoudre parce que le bois ça peut être
utile ça je voulais déjà dit et celui ci
était très très compliquée à résoudre
hier on a passé huit heures en voiture
et je l' ai craqué en fait durant ce
trajet mais pour vous faire vraiment la
résolution du coup je le vous le faire
maintenant tous les cubes sont reliés
entre eux ils sont toujours amovible à
chaque coin par un pivot et l'idée c'est
d'en faire un cube donc comme il ya 27
cube
on sait déjà que c'est un carré de 3 sur
3 qui qui va y avoir à faire et je vais
vous faire la résolution maintenant
aussi en temps réel donc j'étais passé
comme ça après comme ça peut être le
secret de celui-ci et j'ai mis un peu de
temps à le comprendre c'est qu'il faut
faire un peu comme pour le rubik's cube
des rotations complètes de l'objet
parfois pour réussir à comprendre
comment il marche là et là j'ai presque
terminé
je veux faire descendre ça ici faire un
escalier la leur remontée par là vous
mettrez des gros plans après un rassurer
ou est ce qui nous fait enfin la
résolution de celui ci qui aurait été
bien compliquée à résoudre
par contre quand tu mets du temps tu es
obligé de comprendre le pattern la
manière de le faire dans près d'un an
que l'euro faire quand je limite les
yeux fermés bon on va continuer et à
aider et surtout à comprendre comment
tout ce système là ici fonctionne j'ai
l'impression d'assister toujours un
ricochet depuis les recherches que l'on
fait sur et cosy assure moteur il ya ces
arbres là qui pousse je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure que ça génère des emplois dans
la ville que ça génère du tourisme dont
20% est reversé ici pour la communauté
plus les gens qui vivent du tourisme
plus le fait qu' ils ont pu construire
des écoles de choses comme ça il ya dix
mille habitants ici et trois cent mille
habitants dans les alentours alors qu'on
ait perdu dans le fond des montagnes
mais aussi plante des arbres fruitiers
donc chacun mais des arbres fruitiers
chez lui donc ça donne de la nourriture
le sol ici qui est très très secs ainsi
de l'eau coule elle samba sy à des
arbres alors le sol devient l'eau rentre
dans le sol et il reste aussi en était
enfin il ya tout un impact
sur la biodiversité également mais ça
semble infini en fait toutes les impacts
positifs semblent sans semble infinie
juger je suis très ému un je ne sais pas
trop quoi vous dire de plus c'est très
émouvant de voir en fait à quel point ça
peut changer un coin du monde et à terme
le mans ici on est dans une école où les
sensibilise l'écologie et où vous voyez
ils ont ce rituel la de planter des
arbres tous les matins de s'en occuper
ce taux qui font les pousses comme on a
vu à la pépinière jusqu à les planter
dans la forêt pour que les enfants après
quand ils rentrent chez eux continuent
de reculer en fait le message de
pourquoi c'est important de faire
attention aux arbres pour contre pas
n'importe quoi n'importe quand comment
on peut re plantes etc
et c'est intéressant parce que je sais
pas si vous connaissez cette phrase qui
dit comme ça donne du poids sont un
homme et une moreira pendant un jour et
et apprend lui à pêcher tu me nourrir
apporte toujours en fait qu'à une étape
au dessus de ce dicton on pourrait dire
ou à prendre cet homme à faire une canne
à pêche et il se nourrira lui-même il
pourra prendre tout le monde à se
nourrir pour toute sa vie et tout son
village et toutes les personnes qui
rencontrera et c'est exactement ce
qu'ils font ici et c'est clairement le
futur
quand tu entends ces enfants là de
parler d'écologie c'est houphouët
explique ben là chez eux ils sont en
train de planter des arbres fruitiers
pour chez eux et pour mettre de la forêt
que d'après tu apprends que tu as
d'autres personnes qui font dans la
forêt pour cueillir ses fruits pour se
nourrir ou alors pour aussi en faire un
petit commerce et est allé en cueillir
un peu aller le vendre sur les marchés
à chaque fois c'est c'est comme un
ricochet qui n'en finirait jamais en
fait on dissout à quoi ça sert de
planter un arbre battu plante un arbre
ok il ya la biodiversité c'est génial
car l'oxygène c'est génial puis ça donne
du travail à tout le monde et puis ça
fait revenir le tourisme et puis ça
nourrit des gens et puis et puis et puis
et depuis que je suis arrivée en
tanzanie les et puis ne s'arrête jamais
jusqu'au et puis au niveau mondial
parce qu'encore une fois là on a tous
les impacts au niveau local mais
n'oublions jamais que l'impact sera à
terme mondiale et les mondiale puisque
l'impact de la déforestation est
mondiale donc ça marche dans les deux
sens j'aurais pu aussi vous parler du
fait que ils viennent dans ces montagnes
à 1800 mètres à pied avec des sauts de
25 kg sur leur tête avec tout les
pousses d'arbres qu'ils ont fait pousser
dans les pépinières pour les replanter
et ça c'est quelque chose qui font
quotidiennement et pour les personnes
qui habitent ici c'est vital puisque
même si sévère devant vous c'est
complètement déforester ses ravages et
est de ce fait toute l'eau qui n'est
plus absorbés par les montagnes dévale
les pentes et ravage les villages pour
les inondés et faire des coulées de boue
sur les images que vous voyez là c'est
clairement une grande pente au niveau
d'une crête c'est pour voir dans quelles
conditions ils travaillent et replantent
là vous voyez très bien la pente mais il
ya aussi des zones où il reprend dubois
utile qu ils peuvent couper tous les 6 à
7 ans qui vont pouvoir leur servir de
bois de chauffage ou pour construire
leur matériel leur maison puisque ceux
qui subissent aujourd'hui la
déforestation ne sont pas ceux qui l'ont
créé en faisant nos recherches sur les
causes ya c'est pas nous les héros ce
sont eux qui font tout ça à notre place
tous les jours parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix du moins qu'ils ont
si dès qu'il n'avait pas le choix comme
vous pouvez décider vous aussi d'agir
vous avez le lien des causes ya dans la
description et toutes les autres actions
sont aussi bonnes à prendre
je vous laisserai en vous montrant des
images d'une vraie forêts primaires
telles qu'il n'y en a plus beaucoup ces
grands arbres que vous voyez qui sont
centenaires ne sont pas vieux ils sont
seulement adolescents et sur les sites
que j'ai pu vous faire voir aujourd'hui
ils en seront bientôt à 15 millions
d'arbres de replanter sur ce simple site
alors vous savez quoi ne partagez pas
cette vidéo partagée juste ce message
ciao
[Musique]